movers a group that I think provokes a
lot of questions because because of
limits and lines in society right and so
you know we believe or we tend to
believe that people should have a lot of
freedom in the way that they raise their
children but at what point if you're
malnourished in your children is it's
society's job to come and do something
and if they're living not even down the
block but immediately next door
[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Jason Auster
he's an assistant professor of Media and
public affairs at George Washington and
he is the director of the incredible
movie let the fire burn which is about
the 1985 movie disaster in Philadelphia
this is a documentary a terrifying
documentary about a government action
gone horribly wrong about many other
things it's about race it's about class
it's about police talk about move which
was this group in Philadelphia that had
had fractious relationships with its
neighbors and police what was move move
as you say was a group it was founded in
the early 70s and one thing like to
point out about move is it was many
things and it took place over a number
of years early on they were called they
didn't call themselves but they were
called a back to nature group some of
their beliefs included eating raw food
embracing everything that they deemed
life so that was all living things all
animal life and and they were through
their history primarily but not
exclusively african-american but again
always would reject sort of a
classification based on race they were
not a Black Power group for instance
it's also important than in the early
days they were very much felt and I
think we're in opposition to the
Philadelphia police under Frank Rizzo so
they did become more militant over time
but from their point of view they became
more militant not because they wanted to
be militant but very much in response to
a militant police force that was
brutalizing them in 1978 there was a
shooting incident between the police and
move what happened then and then how did
that set up what happened in 1985 so in
1978 move came in conflict violent
conflict with the police there's a
deadly conflict with the police for the
first time and it was in this house in
an area called Politan Village and
gunshots were fired and one police
officer was killed two firefighters were
wounded all of the people in the house
were taken out and arrested one was
brutally beaten on camera later nine
people in the group were convicted for
the murder of the cop his name was James
ramp they became known as the move nine
they were all convicted to 30 to life
they defended themselves and was
somewhat of a circus trial and the way
this sets up what happens later
is that both groups feel groups being
the Philadelphia Police and the move
organization feel to be the wounded
party so later in 1985 the move group
very much is becoming aggressively
active to get these cases of the move
nine looked at it again that's never
going to happen they've been convicted
for killing a cop on the other hand the
police feel as though they've lost one
of their own and that this group has
violent deadly potential and they're not
going to lose another one of their own
right and there had been in 1985 move
had moved out of pal toon village moved
into Osage Avenue in West Philadelphia
their neighbors were complaining right
because move among other things had was
composting and drawing rats to the area
they were blaring things out of public
speakers all manner of night and day so
what happened in in 1985 just very
quickly sketch you know yet I realized
that's a lot because it's it's a complex
situation but so well first it's
important to know that the house is
fairly heavily fortified
okay it has slats over all the windows
it has two large bunkers on the roof
which are fortified and also set up to
have gun ports right and so you have a
group that is known to be armed known it
at least according to the police to have
killed and they are heavily fortified so
there's a standoff the police show up
what was the what was the immediate
cause of the police showing up in 85
they have they have issued warrants for
arrests of people inside the house and
those warrants are based on various
violations and just based on the you
know they basically built this argument
of the neighbors up to the point where
they do have arrest warrants for people
in the house they've evacuated
everything else and and there's a
essentially a huge battle for several
hours in the morning it's clear in
retrospect that at least at some points
the police were reacting to their own
gunfire they are fairly convinced that
there is automatic gunfire and they're
responding to automatic gunfire with
their own automatic gunfire it's fairly
clear in retrospect that move may or may
not had some firearms but they
definitely did not have automatic
firearms they've used tear gas they've
used explosives these fire hoses they
have fire hoses trained on the building
trying to knock away
the different things tear gas all of
this and the group will not will not
come out and oddly there's a quiet
period several hours in the afternoon
they regroup both sides regroup no one
knows what's gonna happen
and the police form a new plan they're
going to use explosives drop from a
helicopter to destroy the bunker on the
roof which is the main fortification
that they are worried about they drop
this bomb it fails to dislodge the
bunker it starts a small fire on the
roof and insipid fire and they make a
strategic decision to not fight that
fire and it sort of adds to the irony
that hoses are already trained because
they've been using hoses as a weapon but
now no fire hoses to put out the fire
five children and six adults are killed
no one adult and one child escapes right
so in the houses general of 13 right and
there is also a lot of drama
so once the house is more than the house
the block is on fire
the police are also in the back alley
where people are trying to escape and
there is substantial evidence that
people are trying to escape the burning
house while police are actually firing
on them forcing them back in now that's
a disputed part of the story right and
there are no cameras on that part and
there are I mean there's a lot of things
that are in dispute this is I mean it's
it's highly reminiscent of Waco it's
almost kind of like a prequel to that
where there are there's a lot of you
know contra contravening facts all the
way around and nobody really knows
exactly what happened yeah I mean that
that's exactly right it's a story with a
lot of but what about and what ifs and
then that even starts from your first
question what is move it's not you can't
pin it down and then I wanted to create
a filmer moment-by-moment you had to
look at these situations so what what
happened in the aftermath of this total
disaster yeah you know in some ways
surprisingly little happened in the
aftermath so there were the adult
survivor was arrested the the childhood
survivor went to live with his father
who wasn't part of the group the adults
arrived a Ramon Africa was tried
defended herself was convicted of I
think conspiracy to riot convicted to
eight years in prison by the way the
people from 1978 to move nine they're
still in prison there were hearings held
in the city which the film also features
public hearings some one of the salah'
most
truth and reconciliation extra legal
body not a court of law that's was
certainly interesting for the film and
interesting for the community but had no
power to prosecute no power to subpoena
so people appeared voluntarily and no
one was prosecuted I mean and no one was
ever prosecuted what are kind of what
are some of the big takeaways from this
or the relevance of the Moo of you know
the move bombing and and your film now
because clearly we you know violent
confrontations between minority groups
you know whether they're religious or
ideological or racial or ethnic and and
the police have not gone away we live in
a highly charged society now what are
what are the big messages here what can
people benefit from in this movie yeah I
mean what most of all is for people to
look around the the world the historical
world and the contemporary world
critically and ask you know there did
this is history and we want to learn
about it but we want to learn about it
so it informs the present and I think I
want people to ask you know where are
where are people where as violence being
done to people with no regard for their
humanity and where are children being
sort of played as pawns in conflicts
about adults beliefs and people without
agency or losing their lives in that way
you know I think you you you came very
close or alluded to it earlier then move
was a group that I think provoked a lot
of questions because because of limits
and lines in society right and so you
know we believe or we tend to believe
that people should have a lot of freedom
in the way that they raise their
children but at what point if you're
malnourished in your children is it's
society's job to come and do something
and if they're living not even down the
block but immediately next door right in
a row that's right that's right and
where is where's the limits of
difference take any right that we have
right a free speech right is it my free
speech to put a loudspeaker on my roof
and berate the whole neighborhood where
and they were extremely good at
provoking those limits and so it really
asks you know as a democratic society
what are we do what to do with groups
that are willing to stand behind their
beliefs to the point where they'll risk
their own lives risk the lives of their
children you know well how do we deal
with that problem and and I think it's
extremely relevant today how how we deal
with that problem and I think you know
specifically the way I designed the
films
want people to bring their own context
to it and it's fascinating to me when I
travel around and people will bring up a
local it's people in New York people say
you know this reminds me a
stop-and-frisk in North Carolina so do
you know about this incident that's
happening here where people's rights are
being violated and and I sometimes I
relate more than others right sometimes
I don't get the connection but I always
want people to be that's what I want
from the film and to - that really
resonated with me one is the incident on
Austria the name of the bridge in New
Orleans the after Katrina and her people
are shot back across it and to me that
same sense of fire and water these two
historical fraud American cities there's
a real residence there between those two
incidents and the other one oddly is is
the drone war right and and this idea
that in our foreign policy we've reached
this point where we have such a fear of
implicating our own troops and and this
you know our guys know no boots will hit
the ground but from higher and higher
above we'll drop more and more powerful
explosives and a few you know innocence
on the ground are killed then that's
that's the price of war not you know and
so those resonate with me a lot but I
Q&A is when people bring up these topics
that I just want you to think about it
well it certainly does that the movie
has let the fire burn it's about the
1985 disastrous tragic bombing of the
move organization in West Philadelphia
the director is Jason Asda he works at
George Washington University thank you
so much for talking to us for reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]